um I just want to start if I may with
Saddam because there's going to be lots
of our viewers who can be very concerned
about the situation there France already
beginning to evacuate its citizens it
didn't feel uh like from that interview
with Oliver Dowden that the government
in the UK has any plans to do so he said
that we simply don't have a scale of
resources on the ground in Sudan as we
did in Afghanistan would that be a
mistake
well it's deeply concerning what we're
hearing from
Sudan and I'm very fortunate as a
Leicester MP to
represent a small Sudanese Community I
know people are deeply deeply troubled
and alarmed at what they're seeing and
what we're hearing from Sudan
as the question around evacuations and
so on it does seem a legitimate question
as to why our government is not acting
in the same way that other governments
are acting
I hope we can have a clarification from
the foreign office perhaps in Parliament
in the in the coming days on that front
um the other well we're waiting to see
what that does whether they do do that
as Mr Darren said it's very fast-moving
situation on the ground in Sudan we were
also talking about the illegal migration
bill that is due to come to the House of
Commons next week
um just to clarify how is labor going to
be voting on that
well of course we don't think that this
illegal migration bill is going to
resolve the problems although we have
put down amendments around those who
have come to the the uh the UK via the
uh by the channel Crossings and our
Terror suspects we believe there should
be a duty upon the Home Secretary to
find those Tower suspects and Deport
them immediately so we'll be interested
to see if conservative MPS vote for our
Amendment but more broadly of course we
don't think this legislation is going to
fix the problem to fix the problem you
really have to go after these criminal
gangs and people Smugglers you need to
have a very specialist agency properly
resourced that is something that a vet
Cooper has been pushing for but of
course we want to we want to deal with
these people traffickers who are
bringing people across the channel
because at the moment they're getting
away with it and that is not right
of course no one's been actually
deported to Rwanda yet because it's been
sniled up in the court so far and what
was very clear from Oliver dad and this
morning was that there is going to be
new powers given to the Home Secretary
to ignore what he would say last minute
requests from the European Court to try
and stop deportation flights does labor
think it's acceptable for European
courts to be able to overall decisions
made in the UK
well across the Home Secretary has sent
more journalists to Rohana than actual
migrants it's not a scheme that is going
to work it's why we've said we shouldn't
be going ahead with that scheme and we
should be using the money that would be
saved from that and millions and
millions and millions of pounds of
taxpayers money
if I may the specific question was about
we should always follow we should always
follow the role of things
of course we should always uh uh follow
the law we shouldn't be acting out
outside of the law but the point is that
scheme is not working uh quite
self-evidently because as I say the Home
Secretary has actually spent more
journalists to Rwanda and we should use
the resources that have been plowed into
that scheme to invest in a specialist
crime agency to really go after these
criminal people trafficking gangs I've
seen very senior Tory MPS tweet they'll
always be these criminal gangs there's
always be people traffickers why go
after them I think that's just
unbelievable unbelievable to give these
criminals a free pass labor would get
tough and would deal with these criminal
gangs I guess the difficulty is you know
saying that you'll get tough and saying
that you'll deal with the gangs that's
the easy bit it's pretty difficult isn't
it to actually prosecute or even find
that people traffickers what the
government would argue is that at least
they're trying to do something what is
Labor's plan other than to smash the
game which sounds easy but we'll put in
practice
but we're prepared to put the resources
into a specialist criminal criminal
police
investigatory Force to deal with our
International allies the conservatives
say they're trying to deal with what are
they doing they're not doing anything
and actually we keep getting press
releases and op-eds from ministers and
Tory cabinet ministers parading around
Studios saying they're dealing with this
and actually they never do they're more
interested in grabbing headlines than
actually dealing with the with the
problems on the ground we've got a plan
we'll start by going after those
criminal gangs with our specialist uh
police force would also deal with the
backlog in the Asylum system as well
because there's a huge backlog in uh in
claims what is the government doing in
response they just Chase headlines week
after week
right let's look at shall we get the
other big story of the week which is the
resignation of Dominic Raab after that
report into his behavior at the ministry
of justice and also at the foreign
office now he has said that he believes
that some civil servants were
effectively out to get him that they
were in his words activists who were
trying to block reforms How concerned
should we be that a senior minister is
saying this about the Civil Service
well look first of all let me say this
you know there's no problem with being
demanding or inquisitorial or pushing
the system hard
I want to be the work and pension
secretary I want to be demanding and
push the system to get people into good
well-paid jobs to lift children out of
poverty to help the disabled people a
million extra disabled people in poverty
I want to push hard and be demanding to
give pensioners security so there's
nothing wrong with that but the report
found that Dominic Robb was intimidating
aggressive and it's not just that he was
a bullying Minister he was also a
failing Minister failing to deal with
the backlog in the courts failing to
deal with the problems in the criminal
justice system and indeed his failures
and with the criminal justice system I
think are symptomatic of a failing
government who after 13 years now all of
our public services are on their knees
and failing so look you know it's right
the Dominic Robb has resigned it calls
into question where she soon acts
judgment in appointing him and I think
it's now the third cabinet minister he's
lost so there is a serious questions
about as to why Rishi sunak up pointed
him in in the first place but my biggest
concern is the failing the failing
ministers and their failure in
government
um I just wonder do you think we're in a
bit of a watershed moment when it comes
to workplace culture I now remember a
very you know senior labor politician
and Years Gone by who people said they'd
witnessed him throwing pens staplers
shoving a printer off a desk are things
just obviously it's worth saying that
none of this was at all a directed
towards a Dominic ra but do you think
our standard for what is acceptable in
the workplace has changed
I mean people should not feel
intimidated people should not be bullied
people should not be treated in a way in
which humiliates them in the workplace
but there are many many ministers in
this government who don't have
complaints about them so you can't so it
is possible to be a government Minister
and not bully your staff
but as I say there's nothing wrong with
being demanding I will be demanding if
I'm the work in pension secretary to get
people into good well-paid jobs and lift
children out of poverty you know so it's
right to be demanding when you're
serving the British public but my
biggest concern here isn't just that we
have a bullying Minister we also have
failing ministers and you know we've got
a government which is failing across the
board not just on public services but a
government that is putting up tax on
working people that is forcing people
are leaving people abandoned without the
help that they need within this
desperate cost of living crisis and of
course the biggest failure of all was
when they crushed the economy last year
and millions of families are now paying
more in for their mortgages or in rent
so we've got a government which is
forcing the British public to pay the
price for their 13 years of failure well
that's your pitch I guess isn't it the
local elections we just heard you give
it there I'm sure the government would
question some of what you are saying
there it's a test for cursed armor isn't
it these set of local elections uh
coming up if you want to be the next
prime minister he needs to show that he
can turn the poll lead that he has into
actual seats at a proper poll what would
be a good night for labor
well look I'm not a sofologist and you
know uh and nor am I going to even
around the block of it you know how
these elections work come on uh I've
certainly been around a long time and uh
you'll also know that politicians have
been around a long time don't make
predictions ahead of the election uh
because the only polls are the ones on
polling day but what I would say is this
what we're seeing from the government
and our sort of is a sort of last gas
government who cannot be trusted with
the future nor make amends for their 13
years of failure they cannot be trusted
on tax they cannot be trusted on living
standards they cannot be trusted with
people's mortgages and they most
certainly cannot be trusted with the
criminal justice system and the National
Health Service and as I go around the
country talking to people I have a sense
that people have had enough of the
conservatives and their 13 years of
failure